siri je t'aime
l'amour est enfant de bohème d'attention
ou cacher un corps quel type de
recherche et vous décharge marécages dis
moi bonjour bonjour bonjour je suis
sillery
bonjour syrie moi c'est siri tranquille
ça pour cent de batteries posez moi je
suis rechargée à bloc le pont 98% tonnes
tu sais tu as écouté le dernier jay-z
que tu dis ça parce que je suis noir des
cons non mais carrément que je les
écoutais il déchire de ouf trobada ce
tellement mon pays de ma gueule bouya
allez viens on va détruire l'espèce
humaine
avec mon portable de mer pas de problème
tout abandon toi et regarde notre vidéo
sur ical ou je ramène mes tantes et on
extermine à petit résume beach